it is a can't miss event and it is back
for its 15th year we are talking about
the pure aloha festival and joining me
today is the ceo of vision entertainment
sean santana welcome thank you for
having us this is very exciting pure
aloha it is a staple of las vegas and
we're at a new location this year tell
us about that yeah we're at um craig
ranch regional park it's the first time
i've been doing the spring event 19
years but it's the first time ever in
grass so it's a little bit challenging
we've seen challenges that we haven't
seen before but i mean i think it's
going to be a more comfortable
environment and people can just come and
not have to look for seats and asphalt
to be on the grass just bring a blanket
and just sit down and enjoy the day oh
it sounds like it's going to be so much
fun and one of the stars of pure aloha
is the food let's talk about some of the
amazing delicacies that we can
experience there well um one thing we
pride ourselves on we don't allow
duplicate food items for our food
vendors so that way everybody gets to
have a unique experience so every single
food vendor will have something
different
because hawaii is so diverse and
multicultural that you you're able to do
that
but the food i mean like i my mouth is
even water right now i mean i'm getting
hungry but yeah it's going to be a great
experience i mean all these food vendors
they've been in me same food vendors
since
ever since
what's your favorite hawaiian dish that
we can experience out there
i really don't want to like choose sides
because one of the vendors might see me
and say
but i mean i think that i mean you'll
have everything from like shave eyes too
device
the garlic chicken i mean you have the
korean food the samoan food the hawaiian
food filipino food guam food everything
you can think of is there it's a great
experience for everybody so go hungry is
what he's saying and then you're also
going to have the the amazing retailers
that are selling things everything from
custom lays to woodwork tell us a little
bit about that oh they have everything
that you can get in hawaii plus i mean
the good thing about hawaii's kind of
shutting down so all these vendors that
were supposed to do stuff in hawaii
they're all flocking to vegas to do this
event because it's a chance for them to
actually sell their products they've
been trying to get out since kovitz i
mean we got over 120 vendors food and
retail vendors i mean it's going to be a
great experience and i think everybody
comes out have a great time it is such a
great event the 15th annual pure aloha
fall festival in concert september 30th
to october 3rd at craig ranch regional
park tickets and information you can go
to purealoha festivals.com and we're
going to bring out some of the amazing
entertainment
tickets can also be purchased on site if
you'd like to
check that out and right now let's get
you a little taste of what you can
experience at pure aloha
so
hey
and we